how do you build a business with a  strong base of operations you talk a lot  about sales and marketing  but how  how do we do it that that sales and  marketing go into a strong base of  operations and process  how do you go what advice would you give  an entrepreneur to build that strong you  need a strong culture you have to have a  strong culture and the culture starts  with the leadership right so  if  i'm trying to teach and this is what  happens in big companies  and causes big companies to fail is the  ceo often is not really connected to  what's happening on the ground  and  it's one of the reasons we've been so  successful in america crowdfunding yes  against conglomerates  culture is the leadership calls out the  people around me keeps everybody sharp  exactly or you have a culture where  everybody's asleep  you have culture either way it's like  what culture